Jaqueline for your work on the revenant
whose costume did you work on first
Lia's definitely and what was the the
reason because you felt to Center I
think it was important to figure out his
character and what he would wear and to
tell the story of his character
especially for alejandro
he's the pivotal point of the story of
course it's the story of Hugh glass and
I felt that if I had his look
established and the feeling for it and
the emotion of that costume that that
costume would evoke it would kind of
determine the people around him because
I felt he was a quite a different
character than the other trappers for
the most part he wasn't a trapper he
trapped for food and survival but he was
looking for something much different out
in the wilderness than the other
trappers he it was more of a spiritual
quest for him he had lived with the
Native Americans
he communed with the animals it was a
kind of commonality between Leo and and
nature that he and the animals were in
it together surviving in this very very
extreme environment and they used each
other or fought each other or did
whatever and I thought that all had to
be embodied in his costume and I knew he
was the most important character
spiritually for Alejandro who's a
metaphorical director so early on I
showed Alejandro two pictures one was
Anna Ricker a hunter not a not a warrior
a hunter
in a long knee-length fur leather coat
with a hood and he was very monk-like
and Alejandro really responded to that
it was and then I showed him a Russian
icon of a Russian monk in the early
1800s and Leo's costume started evolving
from those two pictures do you remember
when he first tried on that the coat
that this monk like very well alejandra
was there in the room and I had my
cutter fitter Rosalie Lee who's
brilliant in the room and he put it on
and he just he already had his beard and
he put her on and he looked like a
mystic almost and I knew Alejandro would
respond I had three versions but there
was one version when I took a picture of
him he was almost Jesus like it looked
like a Russian icon his eyes just lit up
the room and all this beard and the fur
of the hood and the leather and I I saw
Leo's whole body language changing he
went from modern to mountain man in
about five minutes it was amazing it was
an amazing transformation and when we
took fitting pictures of him in that
room and the light was coming in it was
we were in Calgary and the light off the
Rockies was it was all one side of the
room was glass and it was just shining
in on him and it was like he was in this
like beam of light like from heaven and
he just lit up I mean it was quite an
amazing moment I'll never forget it
you